la vie sans pétrole c'est le thème de la
conférence qui se tiendra le 13 juin
donc à elancourt à 20h30 bonsoir à
dominique schiavi vous êtes animateur de
villiers saint frédéric en transition et
puis bon soir à chloe king zig vous êtes
le président d'attac 60,18 sud
vous êtes les organisateurs de ce
rendez-vous qui vient conclure pour
cette année le cycle de l'université
populaire on avait l'occasion de vous
recevoir pour en parler
vous avez traité aussi bien et l'on
court mais aussi à poissy puisque
c'était le jeudi en alternance sur ces
deux communes
elle est question des banques des
transports en commun de la révolution
française également
et puis donc prochainement du pétrole
quel bilan déjà on peut faire de cette
université populaire ça a bien
fonctionné ça très très bien fonctionné
on a eu à peu près 700 personnes sur la
dizaine de séances donc avec des
sciences qui allaient de 50 60 personnes
à 90 120 personnes il ya eu énormément
de téléchargement sur radio marmite il
ya eu 700 registre s étaient des
émissions sont envoyés sur la radio
locale afin de radio locale il ya eu
cinq mille enregistrements 5000
téléchargements
ce qui est vraiment très bien et on a de
très très bons échos des participants et
chose assez incroyable nous qui
organisons des conférences assez
régulièrement
on a un public à peu près un public
cible je dirais et là on a eu un public
nouveau dans cette cible est justement
quels étaient les puisqu'elle est le
public nouveau qui est venu voir le
public nouveau c'est du public comme eux
comme toucher pas via les mails via la
diffusion sur internet mais qui est venu
parce que les programmes étaient déposés
dans les médiathèques et dans les
librairies
il ya eu un gros travail aussi fait
parler d'eux librairie avec lequel on
est en partenariat la librairie pavé la
librairie la réserve sûrement et donc
des gens qui venaient dans ses
librairies ont vu les programmer
on trouvait les programmes intéressants
et sont venus nous et c'est vrai qu'on
découvre un public un peu nouveau on
peut peut-être rappeler l'objectif aussi
de ce rendez-vous de cette université
populaire
l'objectif de cette université c'est de
faire de l'éducation populaire et donc
de présenter des sciences qui traitent à
la fois de l'histoire de l'économie et
de la politique avec la condition de ne
pas avoir besoin de pré requis allez on
demande à la fois aux aux formateurs aux
intervenants du comité local ou aux
intervenants extérieurs de faire un
effort pour avoir un discours qui
s'adapte à monsieur tout le monde je
dirais donc c'est presque moi je trouve
que c'est assez bien réussi et les échos
là aussi sont vraiment très très bon on
va parler à tout à l'heure mais vous
allez relancer cette université
populaire dès la rentrée prochaine alors
le prochain rendez vous déjà pour
conclure cette cession
ce sera le 13 juin à elancourt sur le
thème demain comment je mange sans
pétrole peut peut-être s'intéresser à ce
thème c'est quand on pense au pétrole on
peut penser au moyen de locomotion mais
pourquoi cette thématique du comment je
mange sans pétrole
et bien justement parce que le pétrole
ça rentre dans les transports mais ça
rentre dans toute notre vie et ça rentre
particulièrement dans la production
alimentaire mondiale et s'éteint une
production importante et connaissant en
dehors des problèmes économiques de de
travail qui sont posées par les hommes
politiques
nos deux des filles qui sont la
déplétion énergétique et les
dérèglements climatiques sont maltraités
pour l'instant et donc les notre devoir
en sachant un certain nombre de choses
factuelles de les porter à la
connaissance publique
vous êtes animateur de villiers saint
frédéric en transition ce sont des
problématiques que vous abordez oui ce
sont des problématiques locales c'est
des pros matic qui sont aussi abordés
par 51 transition qui est une grande
grande fille par rapport à nuuk parce
que nous sommes dans une petite commune
mais la démarche est la même on peut
peut-être préciser un vie en transition
que c'est une association liée au réseau
des villes en transition créé en
angleterre en 2006 pour justement
inciter les citoyens à prendre
conscience de ce pic énergétique de la
nécessaire transition
vous parliez des réponses politiques
n'étaient pas adaptées aujourd'hui
quelles seraient les solutions à mettre
en place celle que vous préconisez
par exemple les solutions à mettre en
place ce serait de 2 de savoir et de
tenir compte du fait qu'on va
actuellement 85% l'énergie consommée sur
la planète vient des fossiles et du
nucléaire et que ils vont être en
dépression sérieuse à partir de 2015 et
que donc il va falloir s'adapter
il va falloir s'adapter il fallait oser
les sources d'énergie à 12 soit à des
nouvelles sources d'énergie mais compte
tenu du problème de volume
il va falloir vivre autrement ça veut
dire être des grands changements c'est
ce que vous préconisez c'est forcément
des grands changements et vous pensez
que le public est réceptif sur ce genre
de choses parce qu'on entend toujours ce
discours de il faut des grands
changements dont tout le monde dira bien
sûr je veux bien changer les choses les
choses ne changent pas le choix je ne
change pas alors attendre d'être au pied
du mur eh bien il faut que les opinions
publiques bouger est un des grands
principes des villes en transition c'est
de faire bouger les opinions publiques
locales pour impressionner les élus
locaux et faire changer de politique
partir de la base des éléments qui
peuvent changer des choses non c'est une
interprète appropriation de la
démocratie alors vous allez intervenir
sur ce rendez vous du 13 juin comment ça
va se dérouler c'est une conférence et
un débat ya des points de vue
contradictoires
quel sera le alors le principe le
principe même c'est que je ne suis pas
un scientifique je ne suis pas un
spécialiste je suis un citoyen informé
et donc je vais rapporter factuellement
ce que je connais
sous forme d'un exposé illustré et qui
durera les trois quarts de la soirée est
le dernier quart sera réservé aux
questions de la salle et on débattra des
sujets des divers sujets qui vont être
abordés parce qu on ne peut pas aborder
ces problèmes là sont abordés d'abord le
problème de l'énergie ceate c'est le
problème majeur
ensuite l'énergie dans l'alimentation
donc le problème de l'agriculture quelle
est sa nature etc et enfin le problème
de la démographie
personne aujourd'hui ne parle de la
démographie même les dernières là on est
dans l'actualité les les tentations
autour de la vie familiale fous
complètement l'impasse sur le fait que
ou ne sait plus comment on va fabriquer
le gâteau parce qu'on va pu avoir assez
d'énergie mais où sept ou s'adresse pas
du tout nombre de parts qui vont se
partager bien de la natalité
eh bien il faut au moins ne pas
l'encourager satisfait la politique la
politique actuellement c'est
d'encourager puisque ou ne fait rien ou
premier enfant alors que c'est le
premier enfant qui coûte le plus aux
familles et par contre on aide le
deuxième un peu et massivement le
troisième le quatrième ceci va évoluer
effectivement avec les questions des
allocations familiales mais c'est un
tout autre débat cette thématique du
pétrole vous souhaitiez véritablement
l'aborder au sein de cette université
c'est un petit peu le coeur du problème
de l'ensemble des problèmes aussi acquis
sont traités par par attac
ce n'est pas le coeur du problème est un
problème
un parmi d'autres parce que j'étais
drôle des coupes beaucoup de
problématiques
c'est beau oui tout à fait et puis
surtout le pétrole c'est quelque chose
qui permet à travers cette conférence la
d'envisager le futur et d'envisager des
axes possibles sur le futur et comme l'a
dit dominique c'est quelque chose soit
on va être en capacité de le faire de
façon douce par la réflexion de façon
douce soit on le fera de manière
beaucoup plus rapide parce qu'on sera
comme nous l'avait dit tout à l'heure au
pied du mur
- comment je mange son pétrole jeudi 13
juin 20h30 c'est gratuit mais c'est sur
inscription ses conseillers un numéro de
téléphone qui s'affiche sur sur votre
écran
l'université sera cette thématique
université populaire va revenir l'année
prochaine
oui l'université continue l'année
prochaine le programme est pratiquement
clos ce qu'on peut dire c'est que la
première séance sera le 17 jeudi 7
octobre pardon toujours au prisme et
c'est emmanuel todd qui animera cette
cette émission juste un tout petit clin
d'oeil à tv fils il serait intéressant
que de temps en temps des séances ou
peut être filmé ou tout au moins en
partie ses cinq sens et d'un problème
effectivement effectivement parlé sur
d'autres rendez-vous et leurs antennes
et je vous le dis tout de suite ce n'est
pas ici que pour cette table qu'on va
trancher la question merci à tous les
deux je rappelle que marmite fm et votre
partenaire et que c'est enregistré les
blogs sont à retrouver sur cette radio
radio locale de trappes